hey everyone
good to see you guys metaphorically of
course to see you i don't see anything
right now
maybe one day we'll have technology
where we could all be in such a large
group together in a sensible way not yet
but thanks for joining us as you no
doubt know today i'm going to have a
conversation with
the newly announced nobel prize winner
in physics andre guess who shared the
prize
if you were following the news just uh i
don't know two three weeks ago
something of that sort and we're going
to be talking about all sorts of things
to do with
the center of the galaxy black holes
mysteries
observations things of that sort that
are
pretty vital to the health and
well-being of the cosmos
but let me begin before we get to that
andrea will join us about 3 25 3 30
something like that
but just to um get us all into the right
frame of mind let's just take a
quick tour through some of the recent
announcements
recent news in physics and science
first off you may recall that not too
long ago we had a little conversation
about this
observation of phosphine in the
atmosphere of venus
this is an interesting announcement that
suggested
underscore suggested the possibility
that maybe there is some form of life
on venuses there was no other natural
process by which
that phosphine would be produced so that
was pretty exciting
you know we usually think about martians
we don't usually think about i don't
know what the name is
the nuvians or venisivens
or i don't know someone's got to tell me
what are what are people from venus
called but anyway so it was an
interesting possibility
but let me just show you have a little
abstract here if you can bring it up
of a recent paper that did a re-analysis
of no this is the other one that i'm
going to talk about in a moment so let's
go to the other
the other paper if you would this is the
uh phosphine
paper and in the phosphine paper yes
this one
over here the analysis
that led to the announcement of the
phosphine
in venus was redone and these are
subtle really subtle measurements i mean
with andre i guess we're going to be
talking about
other kinds of subtle measurements too
at the center of the galaxy
but these are subtle measurements
because you know you're taking spectra
from venus venus is a pretty
bright source so if you're looking for a
small
absorption spectra of some particular
molecule
you have to subtract out the background
noise the dominant signal
and the researchers did this in a fairly
standard way
by finding a polynomial fit to the
background and then subtracting it out
they actually is a 12th
order polynomial i didn't realize that
these kinds of
fittings would go to that high in order
but indeed that's what they did
and these researchers here redid the
analysis and
found that this approach can yield
spurious signals in fact they use the
same approach
in other parts of the spectra of venus
and there they found all sorts
of signals of molecules that are
known not to exist so the bottom line is
this possibility
of life on venus coming from this
announcement of the phosphine
observation has at least been
undercut to some extent who knows i mean
maybe the signal will come back
maybe it's actually there maybe it's
time dependent
so maybe it's large at one moment in
time and small at another moment in time
but look
that's the way science goes right
exciting discoveries are put forward
people then try to reproduce it and
figure it out
and um in this case it seems like
it is not the case that that observation
is supported by the subsequent analysis
but who knows
all right another interesting piece of
news
that's actually quite relevant to what
we're going to be talking about
today is in einstein's general theory of
relativity
a key idea is the equivalence principle
right do you remember what that is
that's this idea that there's a deep
equivalence between
gravity and acceleration accelerated
motion can create a force that feels
like gravity right that's sort of the
key insight that einstein had
and root to developing the equations of
the general theory of relativity
now one of the implications of the
equivalence principle is the
universality
of the gravitational force the
gravitational pull because if gravity
is in essence nothing but acceleration
then
everything responds to acceleration
that's just a certain kind of motion
in the same way and therefore
if you look at objects that are falling
they should fall
together in free fall they should fault
the same rate regardless of their
composition now we all know
you know galileo famously
or apocryphally i'm not exactly sure you
know did this dropping
objects off the leaning tower of pisa
right
now more precise versions of that
experiment have been done
over the decades over the centuries and
this uh
analysis right here and this other
headline paper that's worth putting up
on the screen for just a moment
is an example of this kind of
dropping things off the leaning tower of
pisa but
actually dropping various atomic species
and seeing whether in essence two atoms
that have
different atomic numbers different
composition do they fall at the same
rate
and indeed to a level of one part in a
trillion one part in 10 to the 12 as you
see in the headline
indeed it is the case that is borne out
by these observations that's great
right another success story of
einstein's way of thinking
about things and uh that
just bodes well for all of the insights
that we take away from my so we can take
that picture off great thank you
final piece of news
is that the white house
bastion of science the white house has
announced the
end of the pandemic it's over
it's over look at this beautiful um
highlights of the press release
ending the covet 19 pandemic
wow that is so great and you know
underneath this which you didn't we
didn't take a screenshot of it but
underneath this
it's also the case that apparently
president trump has approved the riemann
hypothesis
and has also come up with a startling
new approach to quantizing the
gravitational field
so it is a wonderful day for science at
the white house
really just so
deeply throwing deeply throwing what
this white house is able to do with
science fantastic
okay so today we're going to be talking
about black holes
and you know black holes that's a
concept that i suspect that everybody
here is quite
familiar with but look just to get us
all on the same page
before we bring andrea into the
conversation
like what's a little bit of the history
of black holes the history of thinking
of black holes well remember einstein
writes down the final equations of
general relativity this is november of
and you know that's a pretty key moment
in the history of scientific ideas
as he gives us a radically new way of
thinking about
gravity gravity being associated with
the curvature of space-time itself and
with that kind of an announcement
other individuals begin to start
thinking about
pushing the frontier of gravitational
thought
even further along again that's how
science works
if einstein was wrong in his equations
these individuals who
took the torch from einstein in the
early decades of the 20th century
they would have done to einstein what
the
observations of phosphine more recently
did to the original announcement
they would have undercut it or they
would have questioned it but that's not
what happened
the individuals who took the torch from
einstein
it wasn't like they took it out of his
hands maybe they cloned it einstein had
his own torch
he was still pressing forward by 1915
1916 but others who began to
explore the byways the labyrinthine
cavernous arena of insights that can
emerge from einstein's
initiation of this new way of thinking
about gravity with the general theory of
relativity
among those people is carl schwartz
child and carl schwartzteau
brilliant brilliant physicist
mathematician
and he is the one this is kind of
amazing it's not always appreciated
he is the one who for the very first
time in the history
of science writes down the first
exact solution to einstein's equations
of the general theory of relativity i
mean you would have thought
that einstein writes down the equations
and einstein solves the equations to
figure out
exactly what his new theory of gravity
says about the world
but that's not actually what happened
what happens is einstein is only able to
solve his equations approximately
now that approximate solution that
einstein came up with is quite
powerful because it allowed him to
predict the bending of starlight by the
sun it allowed him to
explain the anomalous procession of the
perihelion of mercury
so these were the initial observational
confirmations of einstein's ideas so the
approximate solutions were pretty good
they were able to get einstein across
the finish line
of acquiring observational support for
his ideas
right that's important but nevertheless
einstein's solutions were approximate
short child comes along and doesn't like
just you know
waddle along meander along he's on the
russian
front as we may have discussed in
earlier of these conversations at the
russian front during world war
one and he's supposed to be calculating
you know how a given artillery
shell is going to travel when the
whatever the cannon is set
at one angle or another but he gets
bored
with that and he gets a hold of
einstein's
manuscript on the general theory of
relativity and starts to fiddle around
with the equations
and he's able to solve the equations
for a spherically symmetric body
spherically symmetric mass embedded in
an
otherwise empty arena of space-time you
know think of it like a
a perfectly spherical star out there in
the deep
otherwise dark expanse of space
and within the mathematical solution he
finds something quite curious
which is that if that spherical body was
crushed to a sufficiently small size the
indentation in the fabric of space would
be so spectacular
that nothing would able could nothing
would be able to escape
right amazing and that ultimately is
what a black hole is because if nothing
can escape
not even light itself then
the region goes dark right so this was
again 1916 1917 no one knew if these
objects were real einstein resisted this
possibility
passionately resisted this possibility
he did not think that black holes
a name that came on board much later on
he did not think that they were real
tried to write he wrote papers trying to
prove that they could never
form but other scientists came along and
they found a mechanism
by which black holes can form it's kind
of fun to see it we have a little
video of it we take a a red giant star
which supports its mass through the
nuclear processes
inside of its core and when that star
uses up its nuclear fuel it collapses
in on itself so if we can bring up that
little visual here
yeah there it is there's our our big red
giant star supporting its mass through
the nuclear processes that i was
mentioning
but sooner or later right this star is
going to use up its nuclear fuel
what happens then well it can't support
its mass
so it starts to collapse in on itself it
starts to implode
it implodes gets ever denser
ever harder more extreme this ultimately
sets off an explosion and the core
ripples through the star
it goes layer by layer through the star
until ultimately it blows off the
surface of the star supernova explosion
and the thing is and this is the point
what remains
has no ability to support its own mass
at all and just collapses
right down into
this black hole this mathematical
solution that schwarzschild found and
this was a mechanism that was put
forward
for how these monsters
in the cosmos might actually form and
that is actually our belief our belief
is that at least for the small mass
black hole stellar
mass black holes that we believe may
well be the dominant mechanism by which
they form
with andrea though we're going to be
talking about
a different flavor of black hole we're
going to be talking about
black holes that don't weigh you know 10
times the mass of the sun or 20 times
the mass of the sun we're going to be
talking about black holes
that weigh millions of times the mass of
the sun even billions of times
the mass of the sun and her nobel prize
as we will see
is for the first convincing
observational evidence that the center
of our galaxy is host
to one of these supermassive
black holes that's where we are going so
we'll bring andre in in about
10 minutes let me just turn to a couple
your questions
just so that i know that you all are
part of the conversation too
before we do that so zero skull says
brian green is a charlatan thank you
zero skull
i appreciate that not exactly sure what
you are referring to but i will take
everything in the most positive light
alright so what else do we have here
um um
arjun kr asks about infinity being equal
to minus 1
12. how is it minus 1 12 connects with
infinity that's a pretty important
question and indeed we will be talking
about infinity today at some level with
andrea because
when you deal with solutions of
einstein's equations
that have so-called singularities and
the black hole solution that
schwarzschild found does have a
singularity
at its center a singularity is a place
where some physical quantity
appears to go to infinity
and for a black hole the quantity that
goes to infinity is the curvature the
space-time curvature at the center of a
black hole soars to infinity
so what do you do with something like
that well
it's a signal it's a signal that
something is wrong
so either you try to change your theory
to get rid of the infinity or you try to
tame
the mathematical infinity and show that
whereas the most naive calculation gives
infinity a more sophisticated
calculation
yields a finite number and what our john
is referring to
is that there are places in physics
where infinity arises for different
reasons than it does in black holes
it arises because you encounter certain
infinite sums
like 1 plus two plus three sometimes
that kind of sum
has a natural role in certain physical
theories for instance string theory
maybe just go real concrete here
when you talk about the vibrational
motion of a string
you can in some sense talk about a
string that has
you know one minimum and one maximum as
it's vibrating
or two minima and two maxima it can sort
of think of the vibration as a wave that
goes around a loop of string and you can
consider the number of peaks and troughs
that that wave shape has as you cycle
around the string now it turns out
that there's a certain quantity in
string theory called the zero point
energy
the lowest energy of the string world if
you will
and it is sensitive to the sum
over all of these possible wave shapes
in some sense the sum
of the numbers the natural numbers one
two three four up to infinity
now you would think that the sum one
plus two plus 3 plus 4
plus 5 up to infinity is infinite right
but there are some very clever ways of
taming that
infinity by showing that that sum can be
embedded within
a more general function called the zeta
function where zeta of s is the sum of
one over n to the s and zeta of minus
one is there for the sum of interest but
if you look at z
of s for all values of s you can find
that it has a well-defined finite answer
moreover as s approaches negative one
those finite numbers converge to minus a
twelfth
and therefore you can define the sum
from one to
infinity as zeta of minus one defined by
the limiting procedure from finite
values when
s is not equal to minus one and that's
where this minus one twelfth
comes from embedding that infinite sum
within
another function the zeta function and
using it to define what we even mean
by that sum that's the idea okay
uh does string theory work with black
holes one true
wenker one true wanker wow i didn't
really know
that i'd be using the word wanker
in these gatherings but we have such a
creative audience
in terms of the names that they choose
from themselves so one true
wanker the string theory work with black
holes it does
now i can't say that with complete
confidence because there's still
mysteries about black holes that even
string theory has not provided any
insight to however
there are a number of accomplishments
that string theory has
provided by using the mathematical
architecture of string theory to address
questions that previous approaches were
stymied by
one such question has to do with the
disorder inside of a black hole the
entropy inside
of a black hole and this is a notion
that stephen hawking
pursued way back in the 1970s and beyond
and hawking was the first person to show
that black holes in some sense are the
most disordered regions
in the universe the most entropy in a
given volume
of space is the champion
on that particular scale would be a
black hole of the given volume
and if you ever took an undergraduate
course
in statistical mechanics you know that
entropy has a micro physical description
in terms of the
number of distinct quantum states that
are compatible with a given macroscopic
description of the system so when it
comes to a black hole you talk about
macroscopically how big is the black
hole how fast is it spinning what's its
electric
charge so charge angular momentum and
mass are the
macroscopic quantities that we use to
delineate
a given black hole but for a given
choice of those macroscopic features
how many microstates does the black hole
have that would count its entropy
nobody was able to count the microstates
of a black hole until string theory came
along
and cameron vapha who we've had in some
of these conversations in the past
andrew strominger i don't think we've
had a conversation with andrew here yet
we should
they were the first to use string theory
to calculate the entropy of a black hole
and confirm the formula that stephen
hawking got from a very different
calculation
without counting the microstates first
time that the microscapes are count and
that is a spectacular insight into the
nature of black holes
it's a spectacular achievement for
string theory and you all know
even though you know i'm closely
associated
with string theory i mean i didn't come
up with the idea by any means but i've
worked on it for a very long time and
i've written books on it and therefore
i'm kind of more tightly associated with
it than perhaps
is necessary but i am a string theory
skeptic
you know that because i've said it many
times in the past
but even though i'm skeptical about any
theory until it receives observational
support
just as everybody should have been
skeptical about black holes until they
received
observational support as we'll talk
about in just a few minutes
the fact that string theory is able to
calculate
the entropy of black holes and it agrees
with
previous calculations from a completely
different perspective that left out key
things
left out the counting of the microstates
that is a huge
achievement for string theory doesn't
prove it
but i should balance my skepticism by
saying why it is that
many of us are deeply excited about the
theory
and feel that it holds incredible
promise that is one of the reasons okay
one
more question before we turn to the main
event for today let me see what we got
here
um
um um goes by too fast let's see uh
i'm having trouble finding one that
catches my attention here
um uh yo here's one could dark matter
who asked that question and then it went
away
uh afoul raj could dark matter
contribute to uh supermassive black
holes which are the massive black holes
and yeah i mean
anything that falls into a black hole
the black hole eats it
and it increases its mass because of
that
black holes are dynamical objects
they're not just sitting out there
at a fixed size rather the more
mass more energy that they consume the
heavier they become and as they become
heavier
the event horizon grows larger and
larger and it's like us too right we eat
we get wider black hole eats gets wider
formula you know for the radius of the
event horizon of black hole r equals 2g
m over c squared twice newton's constant
times the mass divided by the speed of
light squared
so right there you have the linear
relation between the radius
to the event horizon and the mass of
the black hole so yes the answer to that
question is
in principle absolutely
yes final question then we go yeah then
yes what do you think about verlinde's
entropic
gravity that's a really good question
and it's a subtle one
what to say well look i think it's very
exciting
that arenas of science that we often
consider to be settled or even
aspects of certain disciplines that we
consider to be settled
i think it's thrilling that later
generations come along
and have new ideas and put forward new
perspectives so
many people thought that einstein's
general theory of relativity is the
right and most fundamental way to think
about gravity
natural thought right but then others
have come along and realized that there
are problems with our description of
gravity
we don't really understand how it
interfaces with quantum mechanics that's
what string theory is meant to do
but in studying black holes and in
studying the extreme manifestations of
gravity
some very clever thinkers and berlin day
and certainly one of them
came have come to the possibility it's
not really a conclusion yet but it comes
to the possibility that gravity
may not be even a fundamental quality of
the world
gravity itself may be an emergent
property of the world what do we mean by
that well emergent properties are those
qualities of the world
that you don't see written into the
fundamental
first principles equations you don't see
them stitched into the fundamental
foundation of our understanding rather
they emerge
from a more deeper understanding
much the way that temperature emerges
from
the average motion of molecules right we
know what temperature means hot is hot
cold is cold we all have an intuition
for that
but micro physically things are hot when
their molecules are moving fast things
are cold when the molecules are moving
slow
and so the motion of molecules is the
more fundamental way of thinking about
temperature with temperature being this
emergent
idea that comes to us
further down the line a higher order
concept
gravity might be similar gravity
might reside in the architecture of
understanding at a higher level
not at the ground floor at a higher
level it might be that deep
understanding of quantum mechanics and
entropy can necessitate that
in certain circumstances there is an
effect
that we would call gravity but it's not
something written into the fundamental
equation so whatever i think about i
think it's an exciting idea i think it's
far from proven
very much in its infancy but it's an
exciting
exciting possibility all right with that
i'd like to now move to the next part of
our discussion here which is to have our
conversation with andrea guess who as
you know just won the nobel
prize or has just announced she hasn't
gone even to the ceremony yet
you can talk to her about that this is
for pioneering research
into the nature of the supermassive
black hole at the center of our galaxy
she got her
bachelor of science from mit
master's degree and phd from cal tech
currently a professor of physics and
astronomy
at the university of california at los
angeles
all sorts of other awards that perhaps
will come up in our
conversation she also has a new world
science u
master class i don't know if it's been
released yet but it will be released at
some point
soon so with that let me welcome andre
guezz to this conversation
welcome andre how are you good hi brian
so good to see you and i realized first
of all i have to i have to apologize
at some level because so so
the announcement that you you had won
the nobel prize came
forward so exciting and and so
i got so caught up because every so
often when this happens you know
they should always call you and i'm sure
they all did but sometimes news outlets
when the nobel prize announced they call
me so i say it you know how great the
work is and you know all this great
stuff
so i'm singing your praises and i
realize that i never congratulate you
directly i thought
i've been thinking about you so much
because of that so
congratulations this is a spectacular
achievement i couldn't be more excited
for you and
this is the best way to do it
exactly you and i had just been like
speaking like two weeks before
about the um maybe it's confidential so
i won't say it but just you know the
little uh
the uh celebration of sorts that you're
having for another
anniversary not not not the nobel prize
so i was so excited to
to hear about this so how has life been
in the last few weeks
oh it's been a whirlwind uh pretty crazy
but pretty exciting yeah yeah
you know i've spoken to other folks you
know who've been in your position in the
past and they say that for about a year
they couldn't get any work done does it
seem like that that's this
i haven't even hit the one month mark so
they understand this is going to go on
for a year well that's good
yeah yeah but you know it's going to be
hard to keep me away from the science
right no it's but it's it's it's great
for science and um
i think and i think if i'm not mistaken
you're the fourth
woman in history to win the nobel prize
in physics which is again
you know what a great you know role
model man it's spectacular so i know
that's very important to you right
you've uh
spent a lot of time thinking about how
to get girls to go forward in
in physics and math and so forth i'm
super excited about that aspect because
i think it's so important to have role
models and i did learn from uh
donna strickland and her email she said
we can form a new club because it's the
first time
two women who have won the nobel prize
have been alive at the same time
right that's right so i guess it was um
uh
uh what is it marie curie was first
and then maria gopard mayor yes
yeah and then donna strickland yeah yeah
that's great that is great
so so we're going to get obviously to
discuss some of the actual work itself
but before
we get there it's always nice for the
audience to fill in a little bit
of your own history so you were born in
new york but raised in chicago is that
that's right yeah well what did your
parents do were they
scientists so my dad was an uh
economist an academic uh so he was
doing his phd at columbia which is why
we were in new york and then he moved to
chicago
uh so that's how we ended up in chicago
and then my mom
ended up as the director of a
contemporary art gallery
oh wow so no scientist in chicago
in chicago yeah great that's great so
you know we're
were you the kind of kid who is just
always you know doing math problems
and and you know strange
solutions to obscure problems and things
of that sort
i mean you can always put together in
hindsight the story or the narrative of
how you
how you got to where you are but i would
say as a kid it wasn't
it was i had so many interests um
i think my early interest in this came
from the moon landing if you want to
create that narrative i was
four when that happened and it certainly
was the first time i started thinking
about the universe
but at the same time do i do
oh so distinctly and this is you know
the family laura is that i
announced at that moment that i wanted
to be the first woman on the moon which
probably tells you more about my family
than
anything else um the job's still open
thinking about that is that the next i'm
perfectly happy to think about the
universe from
the safety of the ground
but i also wanted to be a ballet dancer
back in those days so it wasn't at all
um clear what my path was gonna be i had
a lot of interests
right but by the time i got to high
school um
it was clear that i liked math and
science so i applied to
mit early action so that already tells
you that i was
uh focused um at that point
yeah and so you went to mit i mean mit
you know
especially the first year has a
reputation of being
pretty brutal right i mean did you did
you find that or was it just smooth
failing
all the way through i had gone to a
pretty academic high school so i was
really well prepared for
the the rigor of mit um so
i'd say the first year wasn't so intense
but that you know then it it really
ramps up uh
in intensity yeah but i enjoyed it i
have to say i got there and i thought uh
i've found my people
did you do research as an undergraduate
or was it just yeah
right from the get-go i mean i think
this is one of the things that mit did
really
um well at that time and more and more
universities are doing
is to get encourage their undergrads
into research so i got involved in my
freshman year um in astrophysics and
never looked back yeah and was it
observational
stuff it was actually mit is super good
at um x-rays uh astrophysics so i got
involved with their x-ray group
doing programming for data acquisitions
for a future satellite
that's uh and then i got involved
in optical identifica uh
identifications of x-ray counterparts in
the optical so mit had a telescope
um so in fact when i went to caltech i
thought i was going to do a high energy
astrophysics i mean at that point
i was certainly interested in black
holes and what i was doing as an
undergrad was looking at stellar mass
black holes
and by the time i got to grad school
that's what i thought i would do but
there was a new project
that was
going to use palomar in a new and
different way that promised that we
could look at black holes in the middle
of galaxies so active galactic nuclei
so i jumped on to that and it turned out
the technology wasn't
um wasn't as successful at that point
for looking at
black holes supermassive black holes in
the center of agn so i
i took what i thought was a left-hand
turn
because it's always interesting when you
go in a certain
direction and that's not successful
which piece do you go with so there's
the technology piece and there's the
science piece so i decided to stick with
the
technology piece and look at how
star formation uh was going i see so so
you felt like you were sort of
in that place where do i follow where
the ideas seem most exciting or do i
follow
where the equipment seems like it will
yield the most exciting insights is that
the sort of divide that you've gotten
yourself in
yes exactly and i i think that's an
interesting i talk a lot about
this with my students um as they leave
their uh
uh the phd program you know that they
have to take the next step
and it's always interesting to think
about what aspect of the the work to
continue uh that you have to do
something new but keep that continuity
or that
um advantage so at that point i did star
formation which
in fact has come back um in a lovely way
into the work in a way that i never
expected it to yeah i guess in terms of
star formation in the vicinity of black
holes i guess
yeah yeah so we'll get to that in a
second so
so you know at that stage um
what technological hurdles were there
that that you felt needed to be
surmounted what was sort of the dominant
problem
um it was um
it was at that point it was the noise
and the detectors that just didn't allow
um the sensitivity to these sorts of
things and the
the the technology that i was really
interested in
were these techniques for compensating
for the blurring effects of the earth's
atmosphere
so that you could actually get to the
highest resolution of these of these big
telescopes um so it was
both about the detector technology and
then the high resolution imaging
techniques
adaptive optics it was actually much
earlier people were talking about
adaptive optics at this point but
nothing
from an astrophysics point of view
things weren't um
scientifically mature enough uh so in
those days it was speckle imaging which
i
like to call it poor man's adaptive
optics because it's
technically very simple hardware very
simple
and then the work is really in um the
computational aspect
um right these are these are these rapid
observations that sort of keep the
atmospheric distortions
in a fixed configuration is that the
idea behind
spectral imaging yeah so you need to
take ex short enough exposures that you
freeze the atmospheric turbulence so you
whatever time scale the atmosphere is
changing on you have to go
shorter um so the shorter the wavelength
the faster you have to go
um which is actually what makes the
input near infrared
a sweet spot actually for this this kind
of work
it's it's long word before you kind of
get to the
so long that the whole earth starts to
radiate
right and and so we're when did people
start talking
about the possibility of black holes
at the center of god like what year was
that is that
relatively in the last couple decades or
this an older idea i don't even know the
history of it oh
that's an interesting question in terms
of exactly um
when so the idea of supermassive black
holes as distinct from the
stellar mass black hole came from
observations
of active galactic nuclei so
that's been around for tens of decades
and it was really in the 70s that people
started to talk about the possibility
that
all galaxies might harbor supermassive
black holes so that there would be black
holes that aren't not
emitting um or their surroundings aren't
emitting
a lot of um radiation
so that was suggested by linden bell and
reese in about 1970
um what size black holes were these are
a million to a billion times the mass of
the sun and of course as you know yeah
yeah really that's why we call them
super massive
yeah no it's it's it's really i mean we
we become
i mean as i do but i'll ask you you know
you become so used to these numbers
at some point you just sort of throw
them around but if you actually stop to
think about it
a billion times the mass of the sun
that's just like
kind of insane at some level right
yeah i mean it's like so much in the
world of astronomy and astrophysics
when you start to think about it these
numbers and scales are so much larger
than the things that we
um contend with yeah so it is useful to
stop
and and take a pause so when did you
start to think about
using these techniques to do a real
close observational study of the center
of our galaxy
you know um probably
[Music]
it's always interesting to understand
people's context what seeds the
the the idea so i came out of
a research group in grad school where
that had done a lot of the early work in
the infrared of detecting
the stars or at the center of the galaxy
so i um i as a result there was a lot of
talk and a lot of thinking about
um what was at the center of the galaxy
so i think it was just as i was leaving
grad school that this
it became clear that this would be an
interesting
project to do and in particular with
keck observatory which
was just opening up as i um
was both finishing grad school and then
beginning my
faculty job at ucla
so sort of at that transition time that
there were just a number of things
that were coming together one was the
detect
the infrared detectors had made a lot of
progress so the read noise was getting
um less so that meant that in these
short exposures because remember we were
just talking about the speckle imaging
how you
take a really short exposure so you have
to be able to see the signal
so if you're competing with the noise
it's just it's just impossible so all
through grad school that's um
that's that was the state of affairs but
um that had um
the noise was coming down and then i had
access to cac
which you know which is just as um it's
the world's largest telescope in the
optical in the infrared
and that offers you if you can beat the
atmosphere
um the opportunity to get the sharpest
images from
ground or space so the key there
was for speckle which is what we did for
the first decade of this work
was just to take existing
instrumentation
change the electronics so the the cam
the instrumentation could
uh read out fast enough and then to
change the optics such that the plate
scale
um was smaller so that you could capture
this high resolution information
um so we did that uh put in our first
proposal and then they turned it down
you turned it down but i like to tell a
story to my students in particular
because you know you think you have a
really good idea yeah
but not everyone might agree um and
especially when you're
what was it they didn't think speckled
would work at keck
so cac is a large telescope and it uses
a very different architecture from
historical
um telescopes in fact you have a nice
let's see in our slide deck we have a
a nice picture of that so if we could
show
number 13 um
i don't actually if we could go all the
way down to 13 i don't know if it's
possible so these are the two tower
scopes
um and these are the two telescopes you
can see um
uh so that we characterize how big these
telescopes are
by the width of the mirror the primary
aperture
and so these this is the one i was
thinking about the width here
is um 10 meters which is like the width
of a tennis court to give you a sense of
scale
um and in order to get to that scale the
the radical thing that was proposed with
this telescope was rather than
um building one continuous mirror um
was to put together 36 hexagonal
segments
and it turns out hexagons show up a lot
in nature because hexagons are the
polygon that fits together um without
spaces
to most approximate a circle so you see
this with the say the fly's eye and all
sorts of other
places in nature you see hexagons so
there are 36
hexagons um and so you only had to
polish um a segment and then figure out
how to get them to
to act like a smooth mirror
so the here we have something called um
active
optics so at the edge between every two
segment
there's uh there are sensors two sensors
that sense where
the other one is at um about once
or twice a second so that's very slow
compared to what the atmosphere is doing
but nonetheless when this telescope was
built this was
really controversial people didn't
believe that this telescope itself would
work
but it did but people were concerned
that the accuracy of that alignment
wasn't perfect
and um in order for
speckle imaging to work this really had
to look like a continuous
um mirror so you're trying to line these
mirrors
these mirrors up to a fraction of a hair
width so
people were skeptical at this point that
keck was really working that well and
therefore they didn't think this idea of
speckle imaging which would be
to really capture the full resolution so
that was one skepticism
the other skepticism was that we
wouldn't actually be able to see
individual stars and see their motion so
the idea of this
project was to take pictures you know
like
making a movie one picture one you're at
the next mix and you look for the motion
and so there was skepticism that you
would actually be able to see
individual stars never mind their motion
um
just remind us what was the point of
capturing the motion of the stars
yes the whole point of the project um
was to prove that there's a super
massive black hole at the center of the
galaxy
and in underneath that particular is
really the question
can you prove that supermassive black
holes exist the center of our own galaxy
is the closest center of a gal
a galaxy that we're ever going to have
to see
so in principle you could get the best
evidence for these really massive black
holes by doing this work at the center
of our own galaxy
and we're looking for evidence of the
black hole
by watching how things move so you're
looking at the influence of
of things around the black hole the
gravitational influence to detect its
presence because of course you can't see
the black hole directly because black
holes don't uh emit any light so we're
looking at the gravitational influence
we're looking for orbits
uh the orbits of well the motions of
stars is really where we were starting
and the motion tells you how much mass
is inside that star's orbit so you want
to get to the stars that are as close to
the center of the galaxy so that you can
confine the mass to as small a volume as
possible i mean ideally you won't get
you want to get down to the short shield
radius yeah and as brian you were saying
just a moment ago
that this is um gets larger is that that
radius gets more
larger the more massive the the black
hole is
so getting to the highest resolution of
of cac
affords you the opportunity to see the
stars that have the capacity
or the information to show you what's
inside their orbits
and how what how much time do you need
between the observations
to to have enough of you know the data
points to plot out a trajectory
well that's that's such an interesting
question actually because it depends on
what you're trying to measure
and what we're going after is
is increasingly more precise
or more difficult to measure so you need
more measurement so in the beginning
it was one measurement a year oh really
we've been um
it was i mean if you remember we were
just convincing them to begin with
yeah the whole thing would work at all
and maybe we could um sneak back up to
um number three because that shows if we
show that
the the problem so on your end can you
make this animate this is supposed to be
an animation and if not we can just
speak to the
yeah okay
excellent these are fi the five
brightest stars at the center of the
galaxy
and um if there were no
atmosphere um each star would
appear as the smallest structures that
we're seeing dance around here
but the atmosphere is what makes it look
like continual bug splat patterns
and you'll notice that the pattern for
each star is the same so the atmosphere
has the same
impact over over these stars so we take
thousands and thousands of these
um frames to try to disentangle what the
atmosphere
versus what the underlying um stars are
doing
right right um and so
so you initially you said the project
was
rejected then you had these proof of
concept
i guess ideas you know
what did it take to get you know the the
project fully up and running
it was really that first um that first
getting that
just showing that the images work
because the minute you see these images
um it's clear well actually that's not
true you probably we um
you first need to convince um we first
needed to convince
the um time allocation committee
that the project the technique would
work so it's taking all these short
exposures and making an image
the next thing is to show that they move
so you take two images you wait a year
you take another image
and you see that they're not at the same
place but there's a lot of reasons why
they might not be at the same place
i mean you have to make sure that you
know how to align all these images so
that they line up
so it was actually not till the third
year um that we were absolutely
convinced because you have
three points that convince you that you
have a line so
um you know a lot of it is um
it's sort of interesting because at that
point um we had just
velocities and already at that point
to us it was so clear this was going to
be interesting and
and in fact that was our original um
view was just to get the velocities
but already people started to push back
and say well there's all sorts of
reasons you could have
fast-moving stars um so to us that might
you just have to keep going you have to
show that these stars are actually bound
to the black hole and get full orbits
um so that's what took this project from
a
three-year project to a 25-plus year
project
so you actually have the orbits can we i
think you have an animation
that that orbits right you know in fact
maybe we could sneak a peek at
um oh yeah let's go we can go actually
can we go back to four
before we go to this one which is the
slide before just to show you
um so this is um if if you don't do
anything speckle or adaptive optics you
get
the five stars that we were looking at
and they're big blurry messes
and the black hole is in the middle of
the little square so we track thousands
of stars in fact over a region that's
even bigger than this today today but
it's the stars that are in the middle of
the square
that um are the ones that are close
as we um to where we think the black
bull is and the next animation that
we're going to look at
is actually at 1 4 of um
the little square area and the thing to
appreciate
here already is that without that you
just see one blurry mess okay so
here's my movie this is my favorite
movie in the world i could look at this
for a very very long time
you can probably tell what my favorite
star in the universe is
its name is so2
and it's the one that effect won the
race and we didn't really understand
that in the beginning the naming
convention actually tells you where the
star is
you might ask you know these these names
seem like phone numbers but there's
actually some logic
behind them i'll get to that maybe i'll
explain the orbits first so
um so2 has a makes a complete orbit and
it makes a complete orbit
um every 16 years and that was
just astounding nobody expected this um
to begin with
um so it was really exciting
so it kind of went in three steps
velocities um
and then it was to prove that they were
accelerating so just turning and once
you get to acceleration
you un uh we understood that the
shortest periods could be on order of a
decade because the accelerations were so
great um
and what sort of speed are we talking
about at maximum for like so2
um this one goes at a um just under just
shy of 7000 kilometers per second so
you're getting up to
you know a few percent the speed of
light and that's also interesting
because then you also understand that
you can get into you're starting to
get to a regime where um the effects of
general relativity are actually going to
affect these orbits
yeah um so the minute we actually the
minute it went through closest approach
the first time
was when we understood that there was a
whole
other there was a next phase of this
work which was about understanding how
gravity works
near a supermassive black hole but at
this point
maybe to give a sense of scale again
because we were talking in the beginning
how do you think about
the scale here at closest approach
the separation between so2 and the black
hole
is a hundred astronomical units which is
the scale of our solar system
so this means that we've shown that
there's four million times the mass of
the sun
inside something that is the scale of
our solar system
so if you think about our 4 million four
million suns where we only have one
yeah so it's um it's a lot of mass
inside a very small volume
and this has increased the evidence for
supermassive black holes by a factor of
10 million
right it's a big step forward yeah and
so when you first
showed people that movie that data was
it an immediate
yeah my god you've got it or was there
again pushback
on alternative interpretations or
something else
i would say velocities push back
accelerations push back
orbits no more i mean uh
it was it was clear that um uh we had
won over the skeptics at that point
uh so now it's really about the fact
that we have an amazing laboratory
that's just in our backyard
now you had competition all along this
journey right and your
competitor sharing the prize with you is
it
right is that and that's important yeah
how important was that i mean to the
whole
enterprise i think it was um well
certainly for 25 years
the two groups have been at this and
keenly aware of each other
and i think that any forefront science
typically has this kind of competition
if there's something really interesting
multiple people are going to be going
after it
um and i i'd say
it has been incredibly good for the
science for there to be
two teams um competition there's nothing
like competition for keeping you on your
toes
keeping you working hard um keeping you
honest because
um there's um nobody better than your
competition to find your mistakes
yeah um and i have to say i've been a
big advocate for keeping
um as much independence as possible
between these two teams because
it also affords you the independence of
approach
so while in some sense this experiment
seems very straightforward and very
simple it's orbits
there's a lot of underneath um these
measurements and how you make these
measurements
and what's come out of the work since
then that's
that um it's not so simple so in fact
along with the skepticism having even
for for the orbits
um having two groups come out with the
same result
really helps convince the community um
that you've done things correctly and i
think over the 25 years we've learned a
lot
there's sort of a ratcheting that
happens you know sometimes they're fur
sometimes we're
first sometimes it's so close you can't
tell the
are you difference basically the same
approach are there any fundamental
differences
it um um i'd say that the
most significant differences are in the
analysis
in the statistical analysis how you deal
with i mean this really
effectively ha you end up using
approaches from big data analytics
you have a lot of information over a lot
of time and how you can
combine that how you understand the
statistical
independence versus not independence or
dependence
of things um can have a big um impact
um yeah so that's uh
but you know we learn from each other so
to say that we're fully independent is
not correct it's uh
you take the best you borrow the best of
each other's work
there's another individual who's sharing
the prize with you which is roger
penrose and uh
just to look to our audience uh michelle
asks how are your theories about black
holes different from those of roger
pendleton so i'll let you take that any
direction
you want how are your theories about
black holes different from those of
roger penrose michelle
asks okay so the great thing about this
prize is it actually recognizes the two
two really important approaches to
science so um
reinhardt guenzel and i are being
recognized for the observational
uh work and penrose is being uh
recognized for
for the theory um and black holes the
whole study
of black holes is i think a um a
wonderful demonstration of the interplay
between
black holes and observations
um the stellar mass black holes is
actually where the
you know the theory for black holes
arose and then observations
um followed but the supermassive black
holes are a case where the observations
led and the theory is following so
they're two so in a sense um penrose and
our work
are too complimentary half of the
scientific
endeavor yeah you know i uh when i went
to oxford
i went there because of penrose i
started frozen group
actually back in 1986
but at that time he was so interested in
things that i
felt were too off center of physics the
topological definitions of maths and
things like so i went up switching out
of his group
and sort of you know worked on
strengthener ideas but it was you know
he's an amazing amazing mind so it is
wonderful to see
uh him lauded and for the observational
theory to sort of come together because
in the end that's really what physics is
really
meant to be about um i should have said
that michelle's last name was
chaucer bell sorry if i said your name
wrong michelle
anna gortka also asks the question does
the so2
orbit follow exactly the same path over
and over
again oh that's a really interesting
question
because um you um it comes back to how
precisely do you want to make your
measurements
because in principle it shouldn't
actually come back to where it started
um
uh i mean einstein's
ideas about general relativity predict
that these um this star should actually
make a
a spirograph uh pattern so it
effectively will overshoot over time
and so this is one thing that we're
working on quite hard right now is to
understand
actually the um the detailed trajectory
of
trajectory of so2 and it's as i call it
so2 and friends
but so2 has the has the most power um
to see if we can detect this and what's
interesting is that there are other
effects
um so if if the black hole is surrounded
by
dark matter you actually will see the um
the star go in the opposite direction
uh so um gravity predicts a prograde
uh procession and ex dark matter
um will exp uh will predict we
go the other way and what's interesting
is i would never publish this and i
haven't published this yet
um but what we're current what's
currently emerging in the current data
is actually the opposite direction um
and this is part of what makes these
observations so
so challenging um
that there may be evidence of dark
matter is that what you're breaking in
this conversation here
that's just what i'm hinting at wow
yeah i wouldn't i mean again i wanted i
just want to give a flavor of what's
going
going on what we're thinking about and
why things aren't straightforward
because to get that kind of observation
you have to convince yourself that
you're putting
25 years worth of data and multiple
instruments
changes into the same coordinate system
and while that sounds trite or trivial
when
everything is moving and moving in the
potential of the black hole
that you're trying to determine this is
a it's a non-trivial
um um thing to do in fact if people ask
if you ask me what keeps me up at
night most about the work it's actually
this underlying framework
which um really dictates whether or not
you'll successfully
measure the procession you know it's
really
i sit here and i realize i don't know
the answer to this question which is
what do we know about the angular
momentum of the black hole
the center line do we know anything um
nothing directly and in fact they
um the spin of the black hole will
imprint on the orbits
so we've done the calculation of how you
know how how well do you have to do with
and with today's telescopes you won't be
able to do it so it's one of the reasons
that we're excited about the next
generation of telescopes
so the coming decade
right you should get to the scale of
orbit
that allows you to see um the spin
assuming that nothing complicates it
because you know dark matter is a
complication
so what would it take for you to get to
a place of confidence
regarding the potential of dark matter
to be influencing the orbits
that's what we're working at really hard
right now it says sort of our number one
uh for me my number one um push
within the group i mean there are a lot
of different lines of inquiry right now
because the data set is really rich
we've actually i would say we've um
opened more questions than we've
answered
uh so but this is this is an exciting
one i think it's it's
um it's sort of very fundamental about
our understanding of
how black holes and and uh work and how
they
and their relationship to their host
galaxy so i hate to ask it but i can't
help
sorry so so what was it like when the
phone rang
um i was fast asleep it's 2 a.m here
and they had my home phone number my
home phone never rings
so you know your first thought my first
thought is oh you know who's
sick yeah um but then i answered the
phone
and um again i i probably don't recall
this correctly because i was so
i was so sleepy somebody comes on and
says um
this is the royal swedish academy of
sciences this isn't dry i guess
i said yes and she said will you please
hold so i had a few seconds
to to realize oh my goodness
like could this possibly be you know
your heart just like
um so that was pretty wild i mean were
you thinking at all
that this might be heading your way or
is it
you know just a real surprise it well
i mean that's yeah brian you know it's a
question okay so um i would say
i gave it no credibility
because i was fast asleep my cell phone
was on do not disturb
um i would say for the last
10 years there have been suggest you
know like with your colleagues will say
well maybe
and you know this see you know the the
notion had been suggested to me but i
didn't take it too seriously because
you know there's so many people who work
on things that are
well deserving of this so it's a
complicated process
yeah i mean i'm delighted but i just i
also understand that i'm very fortunate
yeah so you hang up the phone and then
what
i mean you don't go back
who did you call first well first they
told me you can't tell
anyone until it's announced okay um
so actually i only had a half an hour
and they also asked if i would do
participate in their press conference
and to think about i supposed to think
about what i wanted
to say or didn't want to say actually it
was kind of funny they say think about
what you want to say and don't want to
say to the press
but what i did was actually
neither of my kids were in the house so
i i texted
um them and so that i could hit
send the minute it was announced um
i made a cup of coffee and quite frankly
i just have to let me share with you i
was
just doubled over laughing with just it
i think it was a sense of i
can't freaking believe it yeah
yeah i mean just it's just i don't know
i mean again you should take
prizes with a grain of salt i you know i
recognize that and i fully believe that
this one with a few grains well it comes
with
such um it just it's it hi
you know it's it's such a it's such an
honor really
um and i think it comes with some
interesting responsibilities and
opportunities
i mean in a sense you know you're kind
of put in a position
of um
i i think it highlights the importance
of being a
leader in terms of being a spokesperson
for science yeah especially now
i mean with what is happening i mean do
you feel the weight of that
of that burden and the opportunity that
this
provides i mean well it was so
interesting in terms of what i can't
remember all the questions that got
asked in that first press conference but
that one the one that took me
that i had hadn't occurred to me that
really highlights this issue
was somebody asked in this moment
where science is so important given
covet
and where we're simultaneously
not um crediting science or undermining
science how do you feel about running
winning the nobel prize
and if there wasn't a question that put
a finer point on
now you this is your like this you have
to take seriously as part of your job
yeah i mean did you find that you could
answer that
on this i mean had you given that enough
thought that it
well i had actually oddly enough well
not oddly enough but i um
you know i think we're living in very
interesting times
in terms of um how we treat science and
um what this has done for me more
recently
within the last i don't know just few
years is i feel more committed to
teaching
you know i'm one of those scientists who
came to my job
um because i was passionate about re
research
and academic institutions are wonderful
things places to do
to do research and the teaching kind of
came along
but i'd have to say over time it has
become
um i feel much more passionately today
about teaching
than i did at the beginning i mean i've
always enjoyed teaching but
yeah actually i've always taught at the
introductory level
um because i quickly
because i care a lot about encouraging
young women into science and i
i think the best way that i have to do
that
is to be visible and so given that i
have teaching responsibility
i um teaching at that level is helpful
for
you know showing the young men in the in
the room as well as the young women
that um scientists can take different
forms
yeah and so is that like physics one
introductory
yeah so for years i taught classical
mechanics at all the levels
um and then i moved over to
introductory astronomy both for the
general education
and then for the majors and i i have to
say
you know these are really different
classes the you know the honors
physics classes to the astronomy general
education you're seeing
um different populations of students but
um i'd say that the general education
classes were
really important for me to teach because
i'd come out of schools that were so
techie
mit and caltech that it really gave me a
much better appreciation for
um the overall public understanding of
science
um uh and and so in terms of
communicating what i do i think that was
a helpful
um learning learning point so turning a
bit
to to the future i mean one thing that
we've seen over
decades now is that einstein just
triumphs
over and over again it's astounding
right i mean with the gravitational wave
recently
you know your work you know eht's work
you know imaging
black holes so einstein just seems to
come
out on top over i mean you know
accelerated expansion cosmological
concept he didn't like it but still fits
squarely into the theory
so so you mentioned the possibility of
these observations
pushing general relativity to its limit
in a certain context so do you see
the opportunity to maybe find that first
crack
in the armor of general or pivot going
forward yeah i think this
i think this is one of the reasons that
black holes are so fascinating
because to me they represent um
the problem that today we don't know how
to make the laws of gravity
work together with the laws of quantum
mechanics so in a sense
um they almost represent the limit of
einstein's
um idea so while black holes came out of
this we don't have the physics to
describe
what a black hole is so as to me this
means that it
points a path forward to getting a more
complete understanding
of how gravity works so
you just keep pushing so it's
interesting
um that even the confirmation is
interesting it's like the wild west you
just
you keep going forward until
you i mean what you would expect is that
at some point
the imprint of the broader understanding
or the broader concepts of gravity will
emerge
yeah i mean you don't know where i mean
do you follow in detail
things like like the the spec highly
speculative theoretical things on
firewalls and entanglement
and black holes and all that jazz has
that ever come into
you know the things that you think about
i mean uh
only uh in a distant way so i definitely
collaborate with people who are much
closer to that
um and we've um now actually come up
with new ways of
testing um gravity from from these
collaborations
uh the most interesting one recently was
looking at
um the fine structure constant to see if
the fine structure constant is constant
as you
get deeper into the potential well um
but in terms of you know a deep
um moving the frontier forward i'm going
to leave that to the theorists
[Music]
so so you you know are you troubled
for instance by that you know the the
einstein solution from schwarzschild
that there's a singularity
in a black hole do you do does that
worry you or you're like oh you know one
day we'll just figure that out and i'm
just going to focus on things that we
can see
well i mean do i worry about it
in the sense of yeah okay it returns the
work in the sense that i believe i have
to fundamentally believe that that's
telling you that this is an interesting
avenue
to pursue that there is intrinsically
some
new physics or no new deeper
understanding
um that explains why you get the
singularity
in the sense that in physics you know we
believe that singularities
i always say aren't the big giant red
arrow that says come on think a little
harder here
um yeah so i i guess
the answer is to me it's like the beacon
like there's something to be pursued
there's some deeper understanding to be
gained
and you want to go in that direction so
i of course i
see this from an observational
perspective and i think deeply about
well what is it that
we can prove what is it that we can
probe with our tools today
what is it that we can advance so as we
think about um
all the technology that we have um
at our disposal and ways in which you
could push it forward
what's going to help you so that's sort
of a it's almost like a
it's a dance between understanding what
is the question that's answerable
and how do you move your technology i
mean you have to ask the right questions
some questions we can't answer
um so i mean how many do you have a lot
of do you have a lot of students in your
group
today i have a core collaboration of
about 30
um of which um there are about
five um grad students we have
um and then three undergrads we have two
students who are what are called
postbacks so students who are in between
their undergrad and graduate training so
we have it at each level you know put
their post docs research scientists
and how do they how do you when you look
at the job market you look at the future
of the field
do you worry for these students or do
you think you know
they're just they love now and it is
what it will turn out to be whatever it
turns out
um i i guess i over 25 years
i um the students that i've worked with
have been
have ultimately ended up with with jobs
that they're interested in
um so many of them come in wanting to go
the academic route and in fact many of
my collaborators today
as are the faculty here were once grad
students in my group so that's a that's
a that's a
that's a it's a real joy actually it's
kind of like being a parent and seeing
your kids grow up
um and getting to still work with them
yeah
um but in they're also being trained for
many with many skills that are very
valuable
to a wide variety of industries so
we do a lot of image analysis it turns
out the military really cares about
image analysis image analysis
i can't imagine or um orbital mechanics
things that are orbiting the earth so
that's another skill you know that
that juxtaposition and then of course
as our data set gets larger and more
complex these big data analytics
these techniques for dealing with large
data sets large and complex data sets
are really a value in the um in risk and
risk management a lot of those students
end up in
um
yeah in the financial industry in um
and then in the military so you know
student i think that's also an
interesting thing about working with
students is that
con you have to it's like constantly
probing the scientific question you're
constantly probing them about what is it
they want to do
and what they say in the beginning you
know there's usually an evolution
i mean it's like being in college where
there's often an evolution of what your
major is
um and so i think that's an interesting
question to keep
asking at a regular rate because as they
have a more sophisticated understanding
of what the field is
their answer often changes so you know i
think half my job is
um is helping them get to where they
want to go
yeah for sure so there's a question from
some of the folks that are
listening to us right now someone who
calls themselves the perfectionist
says what does this discovery about you
know black hole the center of the galaxy
what does this
tell us about the formation of black
holes did the milky way galaxy come
first
or did the black hole at the center come
well um when we first started to talk
about our results
when things were just at the velocity
scale the state of knowledge at that
time
was such that people didn't know which
came first was it the galaxy
that came first or was it the
supermassive black hole and it was
it so it was similar to the you know
which came first the chicken or the egg
but today we understand that that's just
not even the right question to ask
because and the reason is that if we
look at other galaxies where we think
there are black holes
and we compare the mass of the black
hole to the mass of the central part of
the galaxy
called the bulge it's it's incredibly
well correlated it always seems to be
about 0.1 percent
um the black hole's mass compared to the
bulge
and that suggests that whatever form the
galaxy
form the black hole at the same time
synergistically
and that there's some feedback mechanism
that keeps the growth of the black hole
and the growth of the galaxy in lockstep
so in fact that's one of the things that
i find really interesting about the work
that we're doing today
is at the center of the galaxy we have
this really unique
uh opportunity to see this this feedback
or the processes that might affect the
feedback so
so our understanding of of stellar mass
black hole
formation you know the standard you know
approach of
supernova remnant collapses and so forth
do you think that has a role
in the formation of the supermassive
black holes or i mean
could that be the seed of these black
holes or do you think these black holes
have a different origin fundamentally
so i mean there are there are a lot of
interesting ideas that may be the
earliest generation of
stars or objects that collapse
gravitationally were much more massive
um so more like rather than an upper
limit which
we think about in our galaxy of 100
times the mass of the sun that in the
early universe it might have been more
like a thousand to 10 000
times the mass of the of the sun and
that those objects
um would be would both nucleate
um the the galaxy but also be
fundamentally the thing that grows into
the supermassive black hole
right right so that may be the a similar
origin but from a
different seed if you will if you have
these heavyweights that were
the initial and there i guess maybe that
it might be worth commenting on
the reason that the you might think that
the mass is so much greater is that the
conditions of the early universe are so
much
so different chemically i mean
chemically it was so much
simpler it was all basically hydrogen
and
our galaxy is much more chemically rich
yeah enriched all right just a couple
more we're running out of time a little
bit but i'd love to just uh have our
audience
have a couple more shots and ask you a
couple of
questions um um
so relevant to the dark matter
conversation steve jarros
asked can dark matter be trapped in
black holes
absolutely any mass can be trapped
inside a black hole
um but it is useful to um
remember that anything that approaches
the um
the black hole is actually going to be
torn apart so once you get inside
the black hole you actually lose your
chemical identity
so it the the um but mass any mass is
allowed in
yeah yeah and so what's your what's your
take on um
um what the experience of falling in a
black hole be like a question that
is seeding its way through a number of
people's comments unpleasant
i wouldn't want to go but if the black
hole is big enough it won't be
unplugged until the very end right
but at some point you're always gonna
get to that point
that's right if you're safer and you're
a really big one
when you see black holes when you see
black holes in
science fiction which is you know it's a
it's a staple
of various sci-fi you know does that
drive you nuts at all or do you just
find it fun
do you have an example where you're like
hey that that was well done
that insertion of these ideas i think
it's great
that these ideas are played with uh in
the movies because it captures people's
imagination
and of course the one i like um um
that i really appreciate recently is
interstellar because they played with a
lot of concepts and particularly they
tied they played with the concept of
tidal waves near
a supermassive black hole and we were
actually seeing objects that are being
tidally distorted
torn apart so it just gives a hook
for talking about concepts um
to the general public you know if you've
seen interstellar i can at least connect
um this concept of tidal distortion or
tides
so there were beautiful images you know
of those huge
waves so i totally agree with you but
did you understand the end of interview
hey you got to give creative license
yeah i know
you know your fellow awardee kip thorne
wrote a book on the science of
interstellar really i should probably
take a look at it
and obviously gave deep thought to the
kinds of things that were being shown
and and there is you know some deep
scientific explanation that i think has
to do with
five-dimensional space-time and black
holes in that arena so things that i
would would resonate with but i
on my own i can't figure it out just
watching the movie i would need him
whispering in my ear what the heck was
actually uh
going on there to make sense dinner with
kip
all right exactly to have that film
playing in the background
so before we finish up and again thanks
for joining us today
you know we we are at
a moment that you know is hugely
challenging and i know that you're fond
of saying that
you know when you when you when you have
difficult things
that are facing you those are the
opportunities challenge is opportunity
which is i think a good way of thinking
about it
but you know the only way that we're
gonna surmount the challenges
is if the next generation as we're
discussing before really does
get excited about ideas across the
scientific spectrum
so do you have any words of advice which
i'm always asked about for
you know the young excited student
how do you keep them excited and what
advice do you give them
to sort of keep it going
i guess the thing i um
like to think about um or like to talk
about with students is the idea that
um um there are
there are points in our life where we
kind of get to taking us
a read on where we are when you graduate
from high school go to college
and graduate from college um but that
you should keep going with this
in life and these are points at which
you can assess
um what is it that you enjoy
um and i like to think about like maybe
in thirds
like there's a sector where you do the
things that you are really
that you understand today that you're
passionate about
and i say today because you know five
years from now it might be a slightly
different picture
and that there's this other piece and a
second piece
where um you should be challenging
yourself to try new things
because you don't know what you might
enjoy
if you've never tried it and so this
constant exploration
of uh of um
of ideas or activities or
um things is it's super important it's
super important to kind of grow
that um
that that that volume of things or that
definition
of where you want to be today and then
the last piece i like to think about
is um you know how do you give back how
do you help people
other people or the next generation um
figure out what they are passionate
about and i think you can do that from a
really really early age
so i guess that's that's important
advice
important advice so so again thanks
thanks for joining us and you know i was
just thinking i was gonna
i was gonna say enjoy your trip to
stockholm and the ceremony but
what's happening actually how do they do
it this year
so this year i mean they're working
really hard to figure this out so
there's going to be a
little ceremonies in each country at the
swedish embassy
which will be videotaped and then
integrated
into a small ceremony that they're doing
in sweden so i think they're
trying as hard as possible to keep some
aspects of this
um constant but also working but you're
not going you're not
we're not going so we'll all be invited
next year assuming that
covet is under control but we will be
awarded
um the prize so everything's gonna be
things are gonna be flown
to each country and delivered
it will be something different yeah well
crazy times all right well
congratulations
again straight to you thrilled to be
able to do that
um and uh i know the audience
so enjoyed having you as a guest talking
about your work
on the supermaster black hole the center
of our galaxy and the
trajectory that took you to this
exciting
work that has been rightly awarded you
know the pinnacle prize
nobel prize in physics and it's great to
see you and i hope our paths cross again
sometime soon
thank you too thanks brian thank you
okay
bye all right guys that was our
conversation
the main event with andre i guess i'll
just do a little bit of q a
before we wrap up today let me just
uh see what we have here in our
question list here yeah so you guys
thanking andrea is great because it
really was um
wonderful to have her on um
all right for some science questions or
whatever else you'd like to talk about
let's see what we have here um yeah
thank you again a lot of
people enjoy that conversation again
bear in mind and i'm serious about this
let us know
if there's anybody in particular you'd
like us to speak with here
we have our own ideas but i'm more than
happy to
hear yours i think we're gonna uh
i think we're working on having roger
penrose
at some point soon i think having roger
would be great
i haven't spoken to roger in a long time
i don't think i've
done a public program with him maybe
even
ever i'm not sure but uh you know at
science conferences
i've spoken to him over the years again
as i mentioned he was my first advisor
at some level when i started out in this
game so um
all right um let's turn to uh some of
your
questions um pollard sap
coda are black holes and corks somehow
related are the scales warp so that they
lead to each other
that's sort of a curious question the
relationship between fundamental
particles and
black holes it's uh there are many ways
of approaching
that question the way i'll approach it
is
one that's particularly close to my
heart it's a
result that i was involved with some
years ago
it's a theoretical result where we were
within the context of string theory and
we were able to find within
string theory that there were certain
black hole configurations black hole
solutions
where mathematically we could
continuously
dial down the mass of the black hole it
wasn't like radiating away
mass just mathematically we were able to
find a one parameter family of solutions
where the mass gets smaller and smaller
and smaller as if you're turning a
mathematical dial smaller and smaller
and when you get all the way down
basically
just near zero the black hole
transitions according to mathematics
into an elementary particle not
necessarily a quark per se but an
elementary particle
so in other words we found a continuous
mathematical
link between black holes and particles
and that was a real um exciting
development against within string theory
so
it's not like we can say that these
ideas necessarily describe
reality because we don't know if
strength here is correct but that was
sort of um
a pretty exciting way of linking two
things that
ordinarily you think are just completely
separate
like black holes you think of them as
the biggest things in the universe they
don't have to be that big but we usually
think about them that way
particles the smallest things in the
world how do you link those together
well and i should say this was a paper
in collaboration with
andy strominger and dave morrison and
that paper at least was one
way of approaching your question
explicitly
linking through mathematical equations
black holes
and elementary particles
um okay uh
kavita singh s is time and illusion
people say words like that time is an
illusion
what i would say is time is not an
but the familiar qualities of time the
ones that
we hold dear the ones that feel
intrinsically
part of time as we experience it many of
those
qualities of time are illusory right we
discuss some of these in in
earlier of our episodes certainly in
your daily equation
you know the sequence of videos that we
put out that was the precursor
to the conversations that we are having
now in those
lectures in those discussions i
described how in special relativity time
slows if you're watching a clock in
motion i described how time slows near
the edge of a black hole relevant
to the conversation we're having here
today and that is not what we would
expect so the usual quality of time
that it ticks off the same for you for
me for everybody else regardless of what
we're doing or the gravity we are
experiencing that intuition
about time that belief about time
that is illusory that is a misleading
quality
of experience that lulls us in thinking
about time in a way that turns out to be
incorrect
other qualities of time the fact that
time seems to flow
right we all have this intuition that
time relentlessly ticks forward from
second to second to second
dragging us all forward in time in a way
that has a continuous flow to it
when we look at the mathematics of our
understanding
of the laws of physics it's hard to see
that flow
it's hard to see that flow rather
it appears more that time is a quality
of events that you can use as a label on
an event
that dictates when the event took place
but it's not as though
there is some river of time flowing
forward
that sensation of that flow may again be
the human brain
imposing a narrative a coherent
narrative on the events of experience
so that we feel and we tell a story of
an
unfolding of reality moment flowing into
moment flowing into moment but that flow
itself
may reflect more about the human mind
than it does about
the fundamental nature of reality so
that's my view about time and whether or
not
it is an illusion abi
lohat where does light go when it's
sucked into
a black hole it goes into the black hole
think about
light as a stream of photons you know
it's like
you know stream of particles is what we
mean by a beam of light
and you would have normally thought that
if you are say
you know in some region of space and you
you point your flashlight like in the
radial direction
outward let's say you're inside the
event horizon or black hole and you're
pointing your flashlight what you would
think to be the radial direction
you would think that that light would
just go out
into space but when you actually look at
the trajectory
of the photons the trajectory of the
beam of light in that environment
it doesn't allow for the trajectory to
go out into space the trajectory
stays within the black hole itself and
ultimately goes
toward the center of the black hole
so the light just does not admit
a trajectory compatible with the laws of
physics that takes the light from
within the event horizon to outside
the event horizon now of course
i'm using the classical picture of a
black hole here which is mostly what
andre and i were talking about
the classical solution as she emphasized
as i've emphasized
in these discussions as well you want to
put quantum mechanics into this
discussion
and we don't fully know how to do that
but stephen hawking
partially integrated quantum mechanics
into our understanding of black holes
and when you do so you do find that
in some sense energy particles
can get out of a black hole it's subtle
we'll talk about it perhaps you know
perhaps in one of our more theoretically
oriented discussions of black holes that
we should have going forward that would
be good
to do but that's the one modification i
would make to my ironclad statement
about nothing getting out of a black
hole but module that quantum
subtlety everything that i just said is
our best understanding of how
black holes work i saw an interesting
question here
a moment ago about bose einstein
condensation but
uh here it is zero skull what is the
difference between a black hole and a
highly massive bose-einstein condensate
it's interesting that you frame it that
way zero skull because
in the work that i was describing before
in which we had this nice mathematical
continuum between black holes and
particles
bose-einstein condensation plays an
intricate
and vital role in that linkage
so a kind of bose-einstein condensation
of black holes
is what is the control parameter that
takes you from
the more traditional image of a black
hole to the traditional image of a
particle
so it's a little subtle involved but
that is one way of thinking about it um
ann grove any grove ass does
whoops does a black hole have a lifespan
do they ever reach a critical mass and
explode
any that's a great question and the
answer
is perhaps the reverse of what you might
think
normally when you talk about an
exploding star you think it has to be
really
heavy and massive therefore it falls in
on itself and it
undergoes this implosion that then leads
to an explosion black holes are kind of
the reverse they're kind of different
so in a classical universe with no
quantum mechanics a black hole would
just
sit there i mean it could absorb
material but it wouldn't get
smaller would only get bigger when it
ate things
in a quantum universe as i described
according to stephen hawking
and confirmed by many other theoretical
studies
black holes do allow stuff to
seep out through the event horizon
energy is able to emanate from a black
hole now when that happens
if energy's going out the mass of the
black hole is going down
equals mt squared energy out that means
mass out therefore mass that remains is
less the black hole's mass gets smaller
and smaller
so you can ask yourself how long would
it take for a black hole
to eject all of its mass to radiate away
all of its mass and energy and that of
course depends on how much
mass you start with so for a black hole
whose mass is about that of the sun
the answer is about it'll take about 10
to the 68 years
10 to the 68 years for
the black hole to fully evaporate now
that brings in the second part of your
question which is
what happens at the very end of the life
of a black hole when it's finally
radiating away the last remaining
material or the last remaining matter or
energy that it contains
that's an interesting question because
the temperature of the radiation that a
black hole emits the temperature of the
black hole if you limit use rough
language
goes like one over the mass
that means that as the black hole gets
older
and the mass gets less because it has
had more time to radiate that mass away
the temperature one over the mass gets
larger and larger
so toward the end of the life of a black
hole as the mass goes to zero
the temperature soars toward infinity
what does that mean again infinite
numbers we discussed this earlier
are a clue that something is
not completely understood that something
different happens and for
a black hole we don't know what happens
as
temperature goes toward infinity many
have suggested that maybe
the last remaining remnant of the black
hole
it explodes and somehow there's nothing
left we don't fully understand that but
that's a possibility
you know some have suggested that maybe
in some sense
the physics is such that the black hole
maybe fizzles in a way that this t goes
at one over
m doesn't hold all the way down to m
equal to zero or as m approaches zero
so andy we don't know the answer it's
possible that black holes explode in
that final
surge of very high temperature as the
mass goes to zero
but we do not as yet fully
know all right a couple more questions
before we uh
wrap it up here um
what would happen if you got many black
holes near to each other mr
chet asks well a lot of interesting
things can happen the black holes can
capture each other
if they capture each other the black
holes can go into orbit
and if they go into orbit they can
spiral around each other
and then go closer and closer and then
hit each other
and this is not a hypothetical as folks
who have been
keeping up with the news on
gravitational wave
physics know because we have now
detected the gravitational
waves the ripples in the fabric of space
from that very kind of process black
holes
spiraling slamming into each other
creating a larger black hole in the
process
so yeah that's what would happen and can
happen
if you have a black holes in the
vicinity of
each other um
john hauling asks we talk a lot about
the speed of light for to have a speed
doesn't it need to be propelled by some
force if so what is that force well yeah
when you talk about material objects
you do think about their speed as coming
from something pushing on them
when it comes to light which again if
you think about it in the language of
photons
the photon is massless it doesn't have
any intrinsic resistance
and therefore it doesn't actually need a
force to
propel it in the way that a baseball
needs a force to propel it so in some
sense
that massless quality puts light in a
different category from what you're
thinking
however i could also say that what
propels
the disturbance in the electromagnetic
field forward that's what
light radiation is is an interplay
between
electricity and magnetism that
plays out in james clark maxwell's
equations of electromagnetism so in the
very basic equations
equations i should say that describe the
electromagnetic field you find
that a changing electric field generates
a changing magnetic field and then
changing magnetic field
generates a changing electric field so
you can find yourself in a circumstance
we're changing electric
drives changing magnetic which drive
changing electric which drive changing
magnetic
and it kind of builds on itself
and in that way it's the electromagnetic
force itself that propels a disturbance
in the electromagnetic field forward and
that is what we mean by a beam of light
in the classical language not the photon
language which is more quantum
mechanical but in the classical language
so if i was going to ascribe a force
what propels light forward i would speak
of the electromagnetic
force for that reason
okay uh you paul asks why is the speed
of light constant and you pi
don't know the answer and i'm not being
flippant here
you take a drink of water
what i mean is we can imagine
different mathematics describing
different ways in which something akin
to light would behave and we can
imagine that mathematics allowing the
speed of light
to be variable to change in fact people
have studied
so-called v s l theories variable speed
of light theories
so it's not as though there's some kind
of
unique mathematics that ensures
that light speed has to be constant
the mathematics that we believe is
relevant to reality does
have within it the constant nature of
the speed of light but your question is
asking
why that or it tantamount to why that
mathematics why
that equation as opposed to another
equation which the speed of light is not
constant and i don't have an answer
i don't have an answer as far as we can
tell that other mathematics is not
relevant to our universe maybe there is
another universe where that map is
relevant and the speed of light is not
constant
but some things about the world
as of today we just have to accept as
observationally confirmed experimentally
confirmed qualities of reality and then
we go forward from there
it is not the case that every quality of
the world
as of today admits some deeper
explanation but let me point out of
course
if there were a deeper explanation you
could then come back to me and say
but why is that true why are the
qualities
of the explanatory framework that you're
using to explain
the constant nature of the speed of
light why are they true
so you can find yourself in a regress is
it an
endless regress i don't know you know
maybe there's a rock bottom place where
when we look at the most fundamental
explanations
they're so deep so simple
so unique in their qualities that when
we look at them maybe we'll say
we're done we can't ask
the question why any longer because
the explanations we're giving are so
deep
that they are self
affirming maybe the explanation
isn't just something that allows us to
go up the explanatory
tower and explain other things maybe the
deep explanation is so
deep that it explains itself
self-affirming
self-actualizing and at that point maybe
we would be wise to say we've
we've got it we're done we are nowhere
near
that level of explanation today but that
is the only possible framework that can
imagine where
we would no longer be faced with the
very kind of why
question that you are asking
so michelle way asks by any chance could
we witness a black hole
evaporating if not when can we expect to
see that happen
um yeah so so the answer is
more than likely no let me say why so i
already mentioned
i already mentioned that the temperature
of a black hole
is inversely proportional to its mass
but i didn't actually put any numbers in
if you put in numbers like the mass of
the sun
the temperature that you get i wish i
had the number
it's tiny it's absolutely a tiny tiny
number i'm not going to venture a guess
but
my point is it's not a guess i could
figure it out i just don't remember the
exact number
that temperature is much lower than the
ambient temperature of space itself
about 2.7 kelvin what does that mean
if you got a black hole in space it's
only going to
show radiation outward if its
temperature is higher than the
temperature
of its environment heat flows from hot
to cold
if the black hole is hotter than the
environment then the radiation can flow
out
if it's colder than the environment then
the net
flow of radiation will be into the black
hole not
out of the black hole so you need a
black hole whose
temperature is bigger than the ambient
temperature of space and as i already
mentioned for
a black hole whose mass is that of the
sun
the temperature is much less so you need
a black hole that's much
less massive than the sun
and we're not actually aware of those
black holes it's not that they can't
exist
you can have a black hole according to
einstein's theory of any mass
i mean whatever take take an apple and
squeeze the apple down to a sufficiently
small size it will become a black hole
according to einstein's equations
but it's not something that we can do
because we don't have the ability to
crush a black hole to that fantastically
small size
so so the answer to your question
michelle is in order for us to see
the radiation coming out of a black hole
to see a black hole evaporating
via the hawking process we would need to
have a black hole
so small that its temperature from t
goes like 1 over m
is larger than that of the ambient
temperature of space
and we just don't have access to
awareness of examples of black holes
that are that light
that's the issue now in terms of when i
already mentioned when if you if you
don't have a black hole that size you
could take in a black hole of any mass
like that of the sun
and just have patience just wait for it
to radiate
and it will start to radiate at some
point because the temperature of space
will go down and down and down in the
far future as space expands the
temperature drops
so if you wait long enough sooner or
later
every black hole will start to radiate
but we're talking about
waiting a long long time far
far far longer than the age of the
universe from the big bang until today
so it's not something that you can
stick around and have a chance of seeing
so that's a great question michelle sort
of a great one for us to uh
to end on here in this discussion of
black holes
where we uh had as our main event today
this conversation with andrea guess
again i want to thank her for joining us
and to congratulate her on winning the
nobel prize in physics
from 2020 the ceremony
as she noted will be a little bit
different than the usual case but maybe
in 2021
she and her co-winners will be able to
go to stockholm
and experience the full effect
of being awarded science's
most esteemed prize the nobel prize in
physics
okay so that's it for us for today i'm
not sure exactly when our next
session will be or who it will be but
you know sign up to the world science
festival twitter feed
or facebook or the world science
festival newsletter or world science u
which is the sponsor of all these so
that you can keep up to date with what's
going on you can also follow me if you'd
like
i haven't been that active lately on
social media i don't know i just haven't
really felt it of late but i'm gonna
maybe get back to it a little bit you
can follow me on twitter that's
uh at the green facebook as well brian
green
physicist or something like that you can
find me pretty easily
all right that's it then so until we
have a chance to have this dialogue
again
stay safe look forward to seeing you
then